[Musique]
bonjour bruno nestor azérot bonjour à un
niveau oui bonjour à toutes celles et
tous ceux qui nous écoutent cela vous
avez été réélu député du nord samedi
dernier doit-on dire député du nord ou
députés de cette marque
j'ai presque envie de dire des buts est
de la france entière le député de la
martinique député du grand nord oui oui
mais au regard des chiffres vous est il
uniquement grâce aux voix de cette marie
c'est la grosse ville de la
circonscription sans cela vous perdiez
je ne suis pas un sur deux cela puisque
vous savez très bien que boone nextradio
était seul contre tous et mon challenger
il s'est quand même soutenu par un
nombre important de communes et
notamment sur la façade atlantique mais
je vais tout simplement déjà remercié
les 14000 110 électeurs électrices qui
ont porté leurs suffrages sur le non
gagne là et que l'ombre désirées moi
même et puis rappeler aussi que nous
avons quand même devancé justin pamphile
et abat souhaite et à marigot et à saint
joseph et aux pêcheurs et aux karoubi
guillaume en hiver et a forcé denis
particulièrement sauf le prêcheur mehdi
ville soutenue par ensemble pour une
martinique nouvelle dont les mères sont
en nombre dans son pull martin est
soutenu aussi par an soit pas du tout je
parle pas du tout pas du tout vous aviez
vous une restauration c'est pas beau
père travaillait à facebook à la veille
de la lumière savent pas très bien les
feuilles pas fait et puis rappeler aussi
que cette marine je suis désolé si je
suis le maire de la plus grosses
communes de la circonscription et puis
rappeler aussi que cette maille a
toujours pesé dans le choix du député du
nord que ce soit à l'époque avec
emmanuel very que ce soit avec camille
petit que ce soit avec guy lordinot donc
voilà c'est l'histoire qui se répète
donc que ce n'est pas de notre faute si
nous avons été maire de cette grosse
commune et que nous avons toujours fait
notre travail en tant qu'élu municipal
c'est à dire édifie nos villes et par là
même nos populations nous ont récompensé
parce que l on constatait tout
simplement que nous avons travaillé en
tant que mère et elle nous ordonner le
ticket pour aller plus loin ça veut dire
qu'au delà de cette marine est très
populaire
je suis populaire partout puisque je
rappelle que je suis en tête empêcher au
carbet hautmont 9h fossé denis
basse-pointe marigot et saint joseph et
pu rappeler aussi que nous sommes des
buts est de la france entière
est ce que ces chiffres là ne vous
pousse pas quand même à vous remettre en
question mais il faut plus de vue les
chiffres alors les chiffres parce que
sans cette marie si votre concurrent qui
est lui les chiffres delà de
l'abstention est ce que ça tout cela ne
vous pose pas vous remettre un moment en
question mais met à l'élever oui mais
nous nous nous avons quand même fait un
meilleur score qu'en 2012
est ce que l'on veut tout simplement
dire et rappeler c'est que cette maille
fait partie de la circonscription en
c'était le cas déjà et j'ai gagné parce
qu'il y avait quand même un nom mais
pourtant de 2,2 comment diriger deux
candidats et notamment au premier rang
desquels le cluzeau clémente et la ville
de schoelcher également une très grosse
ville
est-ce qu'il a su mobiliser comme il
fallait en 2012 s'il avait mobilisé
comme jamais fait le clown implémenter à
l'époque s'il avait mobilisé à
schoelcher comme la leaf est sûre cette
marie il aurait été le député de la
circonscription du grand nord donc je
crois je suis pas d'accord avec cette
analyse puisque je considère tout
simplement et jallet de répéter cette
marie fait partie de la circonscription
là ces conditions ces temps de cette
manche et le cher et de chercheurs à
cette marche ou ça aussi c'est pas
terrible au bureau d'aidé aux seins avec
des si on fait beaucoup de choses c'est
exact mais avec 10,6 qu'on arrive à
convaincre l'électorat
parce que l'abstention ne cesse de
progresser oui c'est vrai mais quand
vous regardez tout ce qui s'est passé
pour ces élections parce qu'aujourd'hui
il faut quand même analyser ce qui s'est
passé il y a deux ans nous avons mis en
place une collectivité territoriale de
martinez qui a comme une provocation de
relancer la martinique c'était ce qui
avait été proposé par celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui nous gouvernent
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé est belle
de 2,2 à peine deux ans après mais
toutes ces personnes là qui ont porté
cette connectivité un bain et elles
étaient toutes candidates pour ces
élections là
comment voulez vous que nos populations
aient confiance dans les hommes
politiques savent où devant quelque part
c'est des milliers de gazaouis
pour des postes et ce n'est pas admise
et ce n'est pas possible de l'état du
pays aujourd'hui j'ai peut-être tort
d'avoir raison trop tôt
regardez l'état du pays le btp les fonds
européens le logement social
rien ne va le pays est à l'arrêt donc
aujourd'hui je crois que les gens en
nommant est ce que est ce que les
nordistes n'ont pas besoin de notre
sport organisé pour se déplacer
correctement le petit jeune qui est de
grand rivière qui est de basse pointe il
pas vous en l'autorité des services de
transport puis peut descendre
naturellement fort de france luc hallade
un stage pib d'où un travail et
lassitude une offre de n'être pas assez
influent pour faire débloquer les fonds
mais bon hein papa doc maintenant que
j'ai été réélu bien sûr que je prendrai
ce combat parce qu'il s'agit de mon
territoire il s'agit de mon pays
oui il faut que les hommes et les femmes
qui sont à la 7è s'organisent pour
organiser notre sport sur le nord et
plus généralement sur la marche de ses
travaillons c'est ce pour quoi ils ont
élu deux fois homme était qu un travail
mettre nos populations view cailloux via
vos responsabilités et mettre fin au
travail bas la martinique vous avez vous
avez lancé avec votre ami et frère
jean-philippe ni lors le député du sud
un appel au rassemblement de tous les
députés pour parler d'une seule voix
l'assemblée nationale pour défendre
ensemble les dossiers de la martinique
ce n'était pas le cas jusque là vous
savez très bien que pour la précédente
législature il y avait la chimie savent
que c'est le monte apparente une pièce
vous êtes en train de me dire que l'un
des deux députés qui s'il y avait un
député qui l'empêchait de travailler
ensemble je n'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit
tout simplement à proximité est réélu ça
veut dire que tout est possible
maintenant oui tout est possible et on
va travailler un député qui empêchait de
travailler on peut on peut l'analyser
ainsi mais ce qui pour moi était
pourtant c'est que est effectivement
lorsqu'on est élu papa renault perd on
est élu pour défendre les intérêts de
nos populations
que ce soit collectif ou individuel
maintenant il faut absolument je le dis
je les prenais pendant toute la campagne
électorale
il faut que l'ensemble des
parlementaires des députés notamment
travaillent ensemble comme un seul homme
comme jeune femme de travailler avec
josette manin serge letchimy est gentil
on va en tout cas il ya des dossiers sur
lesquels il faut arriver
fallait absolument que nous conjuguons
nos efforts est ce que le développement
économique partir de l'économie doit
souffrir d'un parti où de telles
orientations politiques
il s'agit avant tout de la martinique du
développement économique de la
martinique est ce que la relance du dp
du btp doit doit être c'est pas moi une
orientation politique n'est pas du tout
il s'agit de l'intérêt de nos pays
donc je pense que sur ces questions là
sur ces points là le logement social et
tout ça il faut absolument que nous
portions comme un seul homme comme nous
en femme ces débats à l'assemblée
nationale qu'on nous a plu à new delhi
pour soyons clairs alfred marie-jeanne
au pichet cela je n'ai pas cité je n'ai
pas cité de noms ici moi je dis tout
simplement que tout le monde l'ait
martinique et le savent vous le savez
également vos journalistes entre mal
fait de marie jeanne et serge letchimy
il y a si vous voulez pas en amour il ya
surtout je ne sais pas si c'est de la
haine mais en tout cas il n'y a jamais
eu
les conditions n'ont jamais été réunies
pourquoi ces deux hommes là puisque la
vaillance sommes dans l'intérêt de la
mort je vous dit que vous allez vous
inscrire de la majorité présidentielle
vous étiez avant groupe gdr gauche
démocrate et républicaine
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que vous
allez rejoindre les députés aux marches
de non non pas de moi moi je dis j'ai
pris fait et cause pour en tout cas le
président pour l'aude pour pour les
élections face à marine le pen et je les
dis je le soutiendrai maintenant on peut
être dans une majorité plurielle et
soutenir le président en live c'est ce
que j'ai fait au sein du groupe jeudi à
la presse qui dans ce gros talons nous
sommes en train de négocier de toutes
les manières j'ai toujours dit que qu'il
fallait absolument que nous constituons
un groupe outremer donc des négociations
sont en cours
donc si effectivement ce groupe là me
permet d'avoir quand même une certaine
liberté de vote
parce que c'est pas parce que man pour
le président de la république emmanuel
macron que vous ment pour le gpa
gestation pour autrui mans compte ça
donc ça veut dire que je serais quand
même dans une majorité mais dans une
majorité où je veux quand même rester
moi même et que le veut descendre défend
toujours les valeurs et les oies perdre
mon pays de mon territoire
ok olivier servat fait fait la
proposition aussi deux groupes
outre-mer à l'assemblée vous êtes
favorable je ne suis pas opposé mais il
faut les voir comment les choses vont se
passer véritablement parce que des fois
il ya des effets danos et puis lorsqu'on
va au fond des choses c'est pas du tout
ça
donc moi je réitère donc j'étais dans un
groupe g de yahoo avait négocié de
liberté de vote
j'ai vous toujours voter comme je
l'entendais quand c'était bon pour mon
pays je dis bravo quand c'était pas bon
je contestais on se souvient du 2 du
débat sur le fait pour tous deux montés
à la tribune vous m'a dit maintenant tu
écoutes
donc si effectivement je trouve cette
possibilité de fonctionner au sein de ce
groupe outremer oui mais si c'est un
groupe autrement plus haut 4 menacé -
boule hingeoise ou pas les cadenasser
par quiconque maintenant parlons de la
mairie rapidement vous avez un mois je
crois nécessaire elle me sens moins
rutilant fin aux fonctions de maire
alors votre premier match joueurs univa
thénard qui va vous succéder en tant que
maire va t'il déjà reçu sa feuille de
route à mais bien sûr mais où un
événement sera le maire de sète mari
mais aussi sa feuille de route boon est
soulagé aussi rapt un élément clé dans
ce conseil municipal non vous savez ce
que je sais faire je continue à le faire
la moue kg le deuxième pour cette marque
va peut-être grandit encore davantage et
bien sûr nous allons porter en tout cas
cette manne pour plus haut en tant
qu'élus municipaux
et puis bien sûr donc la jouer plus de
temps pour trouver les voies et moyens
pour pouvoir réaliser tous ces projets
là et puis peut-être ce que nous avons
réussi sur cette marque les temps sur la
scène christina ne sera pas une
marionnette est pas du tout n'aurait pu
vous ne soyez aussi un élu donc monte à
respecter à ce titre et je le félicite
déjà merci bruno nestor azérot bonne
journée à l'écouté de nos programmes
merci beaucoup râlé livre j'étais très
heureux de participer à cette émission
vraiment chamboulé
[Musique]